[Music]
my meta question is
related to how terrible people are at
actually buying and holding right they
tend to panic and sell so
even with the knowledge that all this
[ __ ] is gonna happen that the the one
guarantee is there's going to be a bunch
of unmitigated catastrophe that is
totally unexpected
how can you increase the likelihood that
you will
not
respond in moments of panic by doing
what
cripples you financially
so two parts of this one is that even if
you look at the periods that in
hindsight we think were the greatest
that existed which for most americans is
the 1950s and the 1990s that's what we
remember is like the golden age of
prosperity and happiness and peace even
if you look at those periods like in the
1950s people were high like do like kids
were doing nuclear bomb drills under
their desks and there was a lot of
pessimism and negativity even if we know
in hindsight it was great at the time by
and large they did not know that maybe
it was like it was good economically but
there was a lot to be worried about in
the 1950s same in the 1990s which we
like today it's like oh the booming
1990s the bull market but even like
people forget in 1994 there was a big
like interest rate calamity where a
bunch of bond like interest rates rose
and the stock market crashed and then in
1998 a big hedge fund uh went out of
business and almost took the whole
global economy down with it like there
was a lot to worry about during these
periods so how do you protect yourself
from that how do you actually become buy
and hold i think there's one thing to do
here there's a great there's there's a
friend of mine named carl richards who's
a financial advisor and he has a quote
where he says
risk is what is left over when you think
you've thought of everything i think
that's that like that's the definition
of risk is whenever we're done planning
and forecasting everything that's left
over that we haven't thought about
that's what risk actually is
and the takeaway from that the actual
practical takeaway is that if you are
only planning for risks that you can
think about and you can envision and you
can imagine then 10 times out of 10
you're going to miss the biggest risk
that actually hits you the biggest risk
is always something that nobody sees
coming including something like covet
where it's you know it's it's actually
not fair to say no one saw it coming but
by and large it's like in financial
circles not a single investor in 2019 in
their economic outlook had a viral
pandemic as something they were worried
about not a single one or 911 or lehman
brothers going bankrupt like all the big
events that actually mattered it's
pretty much true to say no one saw them
coming i think that's generally true and
therefore the takeaway is
you have to have a level of savings
in your asset allocation that doesn't
make sense you have to have a level of
conservatism that seems like it's a
little bit too much that's that's the
only time that you know that you are
prepared for risks that you cannot
envision and if you are only prepared
for what you can imagine again you're
going to miss the biggest risk every
single time whenever people look at my
asset allocation if i share that with
them
it looks a little bit too conservative
and they say god you could be taking a
little bit more risk and they're right
like i probably could but i want to be
prepared for the risks that i can't
imagine
or the risk that like is possible but
like i don't want to even think about
it's too painful to think about that's
the only time that you can be prepared
for the surprises in life
and i think
most people not all investors but the
majority investors
are not conservative enough and i know
like whenever i say that they kind of
shake their head like come on like why
are you why don't you want to take risk
and once a decade
you learn why once a day whether it's
covid or 911 or 2008 once per decade
you're like okay i get it now i didn't
see this coming it was a calamity and i
either like ground myself into the floor
and like i got wiped out or i had a
little bit of extra savings that got me
through
so that's that's how i think about you
know how to stay in the game in a
long-term history where history is a
constant chain of surprises that's the
only way to do it
you